ah yeah how many babies a mother man
typical nobody knows a loose that [ __ ]
right hey what's going on YouTube now
recently a subscriber asked it's been
two years I still don't know how to get
over my girlfriend how do I move oh oh
amen and all honesty dude that is the
status [ __ ] I've ever heard of my life
and I do realize that when I say
something like this there is a lot of
scrutiny that's gonna be coming at me
you're so heartless I'm not heartless
are you [ __ ] two years Oh get what up
listen dude I'm gonna put it to you like
this do you have any idea how much time
you have wasted on a single person which
after 730 days if you had not figured it
out by now
the [ __ ] calm much like a silent fart
she has gone with the wind and you know
after two years a family with your
nutsack too rich you know when a
relationship ends and your significant
other tells you that it's over you
should already know that person how you
are together to know when you should
stop what does city in your room doing
nothing and waiting for somebody to come
around do for you and listen I'm not
telling you this from the perspective of
somebody who hasn't been there I've been
there the first time I ever got dumped I
was 19 and I wanted to [ __ ] die
I was so madly in love with this girl if
somebody would mention her name
a rabbit-ear drop would just come I
might ideally and you guys already know
me and the type of personalities that I
had so could you imagine the type of
friends that I have be [ __ ]
with sometimes you say her name just to
see me cry suffer what you doing today
Jessica Oh [ __ ] you think you
funny huh because I look like that fat
kid with older brother just took the
last cookie look I'm not saying to you
right now that you're not allowed to
feel sad it's your emotions and I get
that because right now in your mind you
just lost the love of your life she
smashed your balls to smithereens she
karate chop your heart in half she
boiled your ball sack in a bucket of
tears but you got to realize when you
tell me that you're waiting for somebody
for two years the [ __ ] that I picture my
head is me what are you going when you
sit in a room with a picture of her that
you have jacked off to way too many
talking about your penis look like a
crumbly egg roll now but what I'm trying
to say right now dude is that she's gone
it's time for you to get it in your
[ __ ] head
she
but trust me even though I have not met
you my friend I know you [ __ ]
you have not moved on because you have
not made the conscious choice to accept
the fact that your relationship has
ended because technically in your mind
you crazy [ __ ] you are afraid to move on
with your life in case she comes back
you may not say it out loud but
internally it's how you feel and the
longer you let it fester its touch the
seat belt and everything that you do you
are the only one sitting there looking
like a [ __ ] dumbass thinking there is
she gonna come back I don't even know
that's just a game we play it's called
hide and go seek for two years look I
hate to say this but you need to hear
this there's a possibility that after
two years Oh what I'm gonna take it back
you need to hear it
shit's real if you don't believe the
[ __ ] guy insane right now that means
that you believe that she has left you
now for two years and she is waiting for
you to become the man that she wants you
to be right there is a higher chance for
me to flip a [ __ ] quarter in the air
for you to lay on the floor on your
stomach spread your butt cheek fall into
your butt crack and have the core to
come out your [ __ ] nose so please
don't do the Korean drama thing [ __ ]
yeah I'm waiting for you okay I waited
forever oh you caught my blood by just
to ethical because I be you break up is
not about the US mentality anymore you
have to figure out what you have to do
to progress with your life whether it's
with her or without her hopefully by the
end of the day I hope you realize that
you want to be with somebody that wants
to be with you as much as you want to be
with them because honestly if not you
will either find out that you deserve
better or you are selfish for wanting
somebody to feel something that they
don't sometimes it's just not meant to
be but seriously by now she probably
said somebody else's dick so just Oh
what is going on YouTube yes we are back
to giving more life advice and getting
you guys involved into what you guys
want out of my vlog topic so please make
sure that you Facebook on me what so
leave those messages on my facebook fan
page so I can go ahead and check those
out and continue to give life advice
send articles send video send whatever
I'll do it so I'll see you guys this
Wednesday and Sunday more videos
videos more vlogging more videos my body
mobility I'll be your Mickey do you
realize it even if you are afraid to a
minute and you do not say these things
out like out like what the [ __ ] there's
a thousand was that I could say [ __ ] is
gone